I have a million questions about space I
always do but when I never have been
able to get answered his laundry do you
guys do laundry in space how do you take
care of that issue you've got a laundry
piles up is there a way to clean clothes
in space no it takes a lot of water of
course the washing machine and a dryer
we don't have anything like that so we
just we just wear our clothes till they
wear out and then you throw them in the
trash and the trash is like a little
unmanned resupply ship and when it gets
full of trash then we close the hatch
and it undocks and backs away and and
falls down into the atmosphere so your
dirty laundry actually gets incinerated
in the atmosphere and wait a minute
you're kidding you guys on the space
station are throwing your underwear your
dirty underwear out the window and it's
raining down on us
so
see you know when you're sitting in the
corner of a room and there's that really
sharp sunbeam coming across and you can
see those lovely little motes of dust
that are falling down delicately through
the Sunbeam yes yeah that's my underwear
I have to ask you a question dr. Kempe
oh I can't get that in my mind